hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel in case you didn't know
pretty much everyone ever is playing
pokemon go right now and it is an app
where you catch pokemon in the real
world in augmented reality there are a
lot of positive cysts firstly i'm
walking a lot more I'm going outside a
lot more I'm more compelled to explore
but also it's a really social experience
you meet people and it's very very easy
to make conversation without the awkward
small talk of what do you do for a
living what are you studying where are
you from replacing small talk with
Pokemon talk is all I have ever wanted
in life and everyone's playing it right
now but because of the way the game
functions the bubble has to pump so when
I started playing I was in a place that
didn't have that many pokemon a polka
stops so the appeal was in seeing
something come up that little grey icon
knowing what it was and wanting to go
find it because I didn't have it and I
hadn't seen it and it was the excitement
of discovering that thing and adding it
to my pokedex I'm now back in San
Francisco where there are perks tops
everywhere there are Pokemon everywhere
and i think my interest in it is
lessening after a week already because i
keep seeing the same stuff zubat songs
do bats on two baths and zoo bats on sue
i think the point where i stopped
playing pokemon go is when a i've
finished the pokédex probably are gonna
happen anytime soon well be which is
much more likely is that i am constantly
seeing the same things over and over
again so i feel like finishing the
pokédex is unobtainable and i lose
interest in trying which is already
slowly happening so how do they fix this
how does pokemon go avoid a bubble bust
the only thing that i think they've
spoken about implementing so far is
trading which is like a count up to what
i want you're gonna make it even easier
for me to get over the pokemon to fill
my pokedex i'm probably going to stop
playing introducing more than the
original 150 or 151 Pokemon wouldn't fix
that because i don't have this same
passion for the rest of the pokemon and
there are a lot of people out there who
want you can be familiar with them I
actually don't care at all really about
the level and I don't care really at all
about Jim's if I see
a Pokemon that has high CP it's like
yeah that's cool but that's not why I'm
playing it I'm playing it to catch all
the pokemon cuz you gotta catch them all
so more gems or improving gyms or
improving the difference in teams
wouldn't really do a whole lot for me
what I think would would be PvP I mean
firstly it would obviously be better if
the combat system in pokemon gold was
the same as pokemon vanilla but I don't
think that's going to happen but then
secondly if you could battle out the
trainer's you would be much more
compelled to level up because you can
get a higher level pokemon i would be a
lot more excited about catching the same
stuff because that gives me the option
to power up my other stuff basically if
they can make it super super competitive
then I think it might be successful it
does also still encourage people to
explore vital the trainings get XP level
up but I feel like this isn't going to
happen because I think pokemon and
niantic are both trying to avoid
conflict I don't think they like the
idea of people getting in fights on the
street because they had a pokemon battle
so I guess my point here is that I'm
really excited about the fact that this
exists I love it right now and I think
that I will remember these two weeks or
this month or however long it lasts
probably forever but it can't last
forever and I don't know how they can
make it I don't know just thought I
would make this video because I'm really
interested in it so let me know what you
guys think do you care about levels do
you care about gyms are you playing for
the same reason as me or what do you
think will make you stop playing and how
long is that going to take on the flip
side if you want playing why not it's
pretty great alrighty that is it for me
today everyone I'm Alana thank you guys
for watching I will see you next time
bye bye